bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nos sur rt france alors première
question que retenez-vous d'intervention
de jean michel blanquer ce jeudi vous at
il rassuré nous c'est flou c'est papin
ça me semble absolument pas clair là
aujourd'hui on se retourne aux
situations qui correspond au niveau
sanitaire l'actuel à la rentrée de mai à
une époque où on est limité à une
dizaine d'élèves par classe ou on
n'avait pas là où les enfants devaient
pas partagé de stylos ou nevers on
pouvait pas ramasser leurs les afghans
ne leur production on se retrouve dans
une situation sanitaire qui correspond à
celle de mai et on a un proto geeks et
énormément assouplies et à côté de ça et
vous l'avais répété à plusieurs reprises
dans le dans votre journal aux
différents sert la sonnette d'alarmé
ben ouais donc nous il nous faut pouvoir
assurer une rentrée sereine et là on
n'est pas du tout dans la sérénité
justement alors il ya le masque
obligatoire qui sera enfin obligatoire
pour les élèves au collège et au lycée
cette disposition est ce que elle est
suffisante selon vous pour une vie
scolaire sans danger puisque beaucoup
beaucoup de parents sont inquiets pour
leurs enfants
effectivement donc obligatoire au
collège et au lycée que c'est ce qu'elle
cadets dès la reprise le collège et au
lycée
en mai juin les élèves de maternelle les
élèves d'élémentaire n'auront pas à
porter de masque ce à partir de 11 ans
donc là il a absolument rien qui a
changé nous ce qui nous inquiète c'est
la possibilité pour les pour les
enseignants de ne pas avoir en
maternelle ne pas avoir à porter le
masque
quelle énorme responsabilité en cas de
contamination je vous rappelle quand
même que l'on explique la notamment dans
département du nord dans lequel je suis
enseignant on va demander aux abords
dans tout le département du nord
aux abords des écoles de porter un
masque à l'extérieur
et une fois qu'on est rentrés en classe
on a la possibilité de lui enlever à que
l'on vous trouvez ça logique
l'inquiétude que nous on a en tant
qu'enseignante cinq syndicats
enseignants
c'est exactement la même que
l'inquiétude des familles comment voulez
vous qu'on obtienne des familles qui a
eu une copie de façon sereine leurs
enfants et qu'on puisse envisager une
reprise sereine et rattraper
effectivement c'est plus de trois mois
de de l'absence de scolarité avec une
continuité avec pédagogique à distance
n'est pas du tout satisfaisante dans des
conditions d'inquiétude
par exemple jean michel blanquer a
également parlé de pouvoir renseigner
dehors est-ce que c'est envisageable
selon vous vous êtes professeur donc
vous pouvez peut-être un peu plus nous
renseigner aussi assis voilà alors oui
bien sûr on peut parfaitement envisager
d'enseignés dehors alors il ya tellement
de conditions à mettre en place que les
enseignants qui écoute se retrouve c'est
assez drôle première chose bon déjà il
faudrait que la météo soit suffisamment
satisfaisantes pour qu'on puisse le
faire un dehors sont dans des bonnes
conditions deuxième chose moi j'suis
désolé ans les élèves ils ont besoin
d'un un bureau ils ont besoin de support
ils ont besoin de deux crayons elles
sont bien pouvoir écrire qu'est ce qu'on
fait on transporte toutes les tables et
tous les bureaux à l'extérieur mais je
fais comme ça c'est à l'otan de faire
autant de contradictions comment est ce
que vous vous préparez à attaquer cette
rentrée on est on est les enseignants
sont inquiet parce que si on écoute les
informations et qu'on a les informations
du ministère de la santé et qu'on a d'un
autre côté les le protocole allégé
assoupli 2 2 le ministère de l'éducation
nationale on se rend bien compte que ça
colle pas ça correspond pas il ya
quelque chose qui ne correspond pas on
va demander alors effectivement on
entend les objectifs de jean michel
blanquer
il faut que tous les enfants reprennent
l'école
moi ce n'est pas une variable
d'ajustement si on veut réussir à
obtenir et à atteindre ces objectifs là
il faut s'en donner les moyens monsieur
ministre et l'est les moyens ils n'y
sont pas on n'a aucun aucune
augmentation de postes on a en a aucun
moyen matériel pour pour assurer la
distanciation sociale donc on n'y croit
pas justement on a conscience que
l'épidémie elle a changé notre notre
manière de vivre de voir les choses
comment est-ce que vous en tant que
professeur locaux vides 19 à changer
votre votre métier d'une manière ou
d'une autre c'est un changement qui
encore en cours
le premier changement c'est réussir à
inventer en un week-end
la fameuse continuité pédagogique c'est
à dire que du jour au lendemain on avait
nos élèves le vendredi à partir de lundi
on va falloir faire il a fallu faire
donc au mois de mai marque phare dont il
a fallu faire école à distance donc avec
notre propre matériel
avec notre propre connexion internet
sans avoir aucune information et avec
des outils défaillant donc là il faut le
ministre l'a reconnu mais il a fallu
faire preuve d'une véritable ingéniosité
mais nous sommes nous enseignants et le
super lap être suffisamment nous sommes
concepteurs de notre métier et les
enseignants ont réussi à inventer
quelque chose c'est pas satisfaisant
c'est pas suffisant mais pour que les
enfants puissent continuer d'apprendre
ou en tout cas d'avoir un lien avec avec
l'école milov professeurs comment est ce
que vous vous êtes adapté ben on
respecte ans déjà simplement le la
distanciation sortir et ça c'est très
difficile quand on enseigne en
maternelle c'est quasiment impossible d
enfants ils ont besoin de contacts ils
ont besoin d'être rassurés parfois ils
ont besoin de bras qu'on leur parle de
façon beaucoup plus proches dont ils ont
besoin d'explications
donc ça c'est difficile donc il a fallu
faire preuve de beaucoup de pédagogie de
technologie de discussion et puis et
puis d'ingéniosité aussi pour envisager
un outil qui soit différent et là les
enseignants ont beaucoup beaucoup
échanger entre eux aussi pour pouvoir
réussir à poursuivre
l'exercice de leur métier mais merci à
vous pour toutes ces précisions et bon
courage pour cette rentrée je rappelle
que vous êtes un professeur et co
secrétaire du syndicat national unitaire
des institutions instituteur affilié à
la fsu dans merci à vous merci le
journal